you probably know this already but that's okay yeah you can fast forward if you need to see
your pattern is scored uh based on the number 10 so out of 10 is your is your one uh as you can see
it's split into two parts we have our accuracy and our presentation so we'll start with the
accuracy first so your accuracy is actually scored from a four so from the number four
um actually marked during your presentation of your pattern and then with that one any mistakes
that you make if it's a minor mistake you get a minus of 0.1 if it's a major mistake you get
minus 0.3 so i'll just let you guys know about the difference between the two so with a minor
mistake it's a very very small thing so say we're doing a out of block if it's not your shoulder
height maybe it's a little bit lower or maybe it's a tiny bit higher that's a minor mistake
so that's a 0.1 a major mistake would be you're supposed to do an out of block in the pattern
but you forget and you say you do a re-chancelling set so that would be a major mistake so with a
minor mistake uh let's say a kind of one for example there's about 20 steps it's not uncommon
to have up to maybe 14 15 mistakes in the 20 patterns sorry 20 steps so the reason for that
would be uh it needs to be absolutely perfect to get uh to not get a deduction of 0.1 so it's not
uncommon to say there's 20 steps and you may even say 15 steps so what would that be so we'll leave
that there on the side and we'll come back and we'll just count them as what they are at the end
so i made a mistake say you're supposed to turn to the left but you turn to the right that would
be a major mistake so obviously we do want to try to avoid any of these major mistakes so uh after
we've done that pattern that's when we move on to the
presentation side so the presentation as you can see it's from a score of six uh this six is
actually split up into three parts so we have one two three here so with this one uh for a score of
two is your power and speed your rhythm is also a score of two and your expression of energy is also
scored out into a block so we'll start with the power and speed so with this one whether it's
your blocks your kicks your strikes your punches anything you are that you do it needs to be nice
and strong and it has to be fast as well so it's one thing to have a very strong punch or a very
fast punch but it has to be both strong and fast to get um high in that category the next part is
your rhythm so the rhythm when you do start your pattern there is a rhythm to the pattern it's not
just really fast all the way through it's not slow all the way through there's a slow fast slow fast
kind of aspect to it as well so you do need to kind of work on a rhythm and that's also scored
out into the last bit is your expression of energy so what is the expression of energy but that's
basically uh how loud you shout so how much intensity you have during your pattern as well
so say you're doing your pattern really well it's really fast and it's strong your rhythm is really
great but you're not shouting very loud or you can kind of tell the judges can kind of tell
you're not really confident you're a little bit nervous so that's why i'm going to kind of improve
on as well so i'm just coming up to this side so with this one for color belts and black belts
it's actually scored a little bit differently so if you're a color belt you'll actually uh your
average so where the judges actually mark you from it's actually from a 1.1 so this is your
average so say you did uh you did all right you did average
compared to everyone else your score for one two and three it'll start from a 1.1 so if you're
less than average in the judge's eyes you might go down to say for your power and speed you might
get a one or even a 0.9 if you did really great you might even get a 1.3 or 1.4 so each individual
uh category you need to obviously get as high as you can if you're a black belt generally depending
on the competition you will be scored from a 1.3 so 1.3 will be your average that you start from
so say your power and speed uh was above average you might get scored a 1. say let's say 1.4 for
now say your rhythm was only about average uh it wasn't amazing it might be just a 1.3 but let's
say you didn't shout very loud so your expression of energy your average was 1.3 it might drop to
say let's say 1.0 so with this one we'll come down to this side so with this one uh as i was
saying it's a total of uh 10 so let's see before presentation we had 0.7 1 2 3 so you had 3.7
and so you made 15 mistakes so with this one obviously don't be too discouraged if you do get
uh pretty high in your mistakes uh this is with the judges we have three judges usually at the
panel and each judge obviously the rest of the judges so uh from their point of view you might
have made a lot of mistakes we may not have made a lot of mistakes as well so that's why we have
three judges and we average it out as well okay so uh same thing now uh 15 mistakes very small
mistakes so
if they're all uh minus 0.1 you'd be 1.5 so you go 4.0 minus 1.5 which equals 2.5 so this would
be your accuracy score so without presentation like before we're saying you've got a 3.7
we add these numbers at the uh after the judges are finished scoring that you'll get for this
pattern a 6.2 which is actually very good so i'll just talk about a little bit more now about this
number here so if you're a color belt if you're a yellow or above and you do your patterns it's
not uncommon generally for a color belt uh the average is about a 4 to 5 so if you get a number
between uh 4 and 5 out of 10 for your pattern that's actually generally considered pretty
good so anything above that uh you can consider yourself pretty good uh if you're a black belt
the average would say because um we're talking here about the high presentation as an average
anything from five to two three five six is actually considered uh pretty pretty good and
anything over a seven is actually considered almost world-class so if you get a seven for any
of your patterns you generally need to pat yourself on the back and do an amazing job so
i'll just go through our full day scoring so just remember accuracy is a 4.0 presentation is a 6.0
accuracy is judge during your patent presentation is after and then we get two scores that we add
up we get that number so with this one obviously uh say i was i was judge number one i will give
you a 6.2
there was another judge on the other side maybe he saw a couple more mistakes than i did maybe
this one would be a little bit lower might be a five point something another judge on the other
side they scored a little bit higher so we get three numbers and then we average that as well
so i hope this helped you guys so make sure you enjoy your competition and anytime make sure
obviously you record down your numbers as well so it's very important to keep track of your numbers
okay okay we are going to watch your performance again
this time we cannot pause like a real judge for your own um minor errors major errors you can when
you see a minor error oh yeah these are adding errors adding errors yeah okay adding errors
real time and then after the performance is power and speed coordination for them and expression of
energy you can rate yourself got it perfect when you're ready press space
so
when you're ready to go you type your thoughts into your mind and then we can watch what's
happening and again i i can't really explain how important this is if you want to but it's
a great way to look at how many times you're living how many times you're thinking how many
times you're thinking and how many times you're feeling because we can't even tell when we take
a lot of things seriously right like i don't even want to think about it because i don't want to
think about it too much when we're doing it so what happens when you look at your own instructions
and you're like okay i'm going to be like i'm going to do this and i'm not going to do anything
Thank you.